in the woods around bakmut Ukrainian
infantry troops are digging in
battles in the besieged Donetsk region
have fresh ferocity
with Russian and Ukrainian troops just
100 meters apart in some places
this volunteer says he made it to the
ice crusted grounds of the city he
describes fires and constant explosions
Thursday he was handing out food and
imploring residents to leave
this woman expressed love and gratitude
but stays
for systematic human rights violations
against Russians opposing the war in
Ukraine Canada just sanctioned 33
current and former Russian officials a
move that led Moscow to summon Canada's
Ambassador meanwhile ukrainians face
inconceivable violence day in and day
out yeah
there was a very loud noise I barely
managed to close the doors and get the
children before the ceiling started to
crumble the walls as well British prime
minister Rishi sunak spoke with
Ukraine's president assuring him more
defensive weapons are on the way
in his nightly addressed Vladimir
zielinski thanked the UK for its support
and expressed the challenges faced by
those on the front lines in the east
in an effort to continue its bloody war
on Ukraine British officials accuse
Russia of cozying up to Iran Russia is
now attempting to obtain more weapons
including hundreds of ballistic missiles
in return
in return
Russia is offering Iran an unprecedented
level of military and technical support
Russia denies that allegation just as
Iran denies selling Kamikaze drones to
the Kremlin after the February invasion
Crystal commencing Global News London